all right reject nation how you do it
it's Greg Alba here it's John Humphrey
over here it's Andrew over here okay and
Jeff in the movie source channel is here
with us today so we put up our reaction
for the infinity war trailer hope you
guys saw our sketch put a lot of thought
and work into that boy man we shot that
at midnight
that was quite a happy time good time
thank you Andrew so much for being here
so early in the morning with us buddy
and John and I are looking forward to
rest after this anyway yeah we wanted to
go through the trailer Andrew being more
of an expert than John and I both yes
but you know John I know a few things
here there so all right dude opening
shot of like Tony Stark looking like
he's in this despair yeah and whose hand
is he holding is that Nick Fury's hinder
is that Colonel Rhodes hand is he
holding a hammer
it looks like he's gripping his how is
that it might be covered yeah looks like
his hand wasn't sometimes or this this
might actually be part of that sequence
that he was dreaming about an age of
Ultron do you mean that Scarlett
Scarlett which the nightmare see he has
a mirror sequence and where all the
Avengers were dead yeah I always had to
believe that that when I was watching
that scene in the theaters that that was
a full an actual scene from infinity war
earlier or that they were gonna put four
shadow yeah because that's I mean it
kind of looks like it could be from that
it's definitely much brighter than the
other one do you ever remember seeing
Tony looking's like well Tony's got
actually execute dad about his parents
and and in Civil War he's been in a much
more despair path at homecoming he was
more of a Toni that I ever met
but a lot of other Moos excitement yeah
and this shot is a callback of Bruce
Banner in there it's kind of a callback
to the Avengers my first one but when
Harry Stanton found him I'd said yeah
son you've got a condition
yeah like they kind of reminds me that
the visual imagery call back a little
bit I'm wondering what's happening here
because they they're traveling through a
scar my my theory is because I read the
breakdown of the infinity war elite
trailer from comic-con and they said
that you know Thor and he runs into the
ship or something like oh no yeah it
runs the guardians and and then and you
know and the end of Ragnarok Hulk is
with them right so I imagine that once
their ship got attacked it looks like it
crashed and fortunately he lands in New
York or dr. strange of one of his
traveling through whatever energy thing
in order to find the Hulk because it
heard about their ship crashed or Thanos
threw him out yeah well it looks like
they first went after New York you know
and cuz I what's interesting about this
to me is a lot of the time you know we
hear people talk about why is it always
going on or New York maybe there's
something more significant wins hey well
you seen the traffic that's it well you
see spider-man at one point when he's
there all talk about that is that
everybody gets where Spidey gets where
spider-man gets the spidey sense
yeah it looks over and it's in New York
what's with the whatever is attacking
them at their total yeah so I don't know
if it's a worldwide thing cuz I heard
this one would go through more of the
worlds and even other planets yeah I
gotta imagine - there's gonna be
different kinds of battles throughout
like with Star Wars in you remember and
usually I can return to the Jedi when
you get like three different yeah it was
all happening at once so I would imagine
we're gonna get some like different
battles like some in space some in
Wakanda some in New York like we're
gonna get different love because the
main thing is in this movie is Stannis
is it's like fan of this quest he's
going after the affinity stones and he's
sending the black order out to retrieve
those stones when he doesn't get and get
him himself so I cannot wait to see what
the black order is gonna be that's gonna
be awesome this moment really stood out
to all of us anything human when you
when you see
vision vision as Paul Bettany that's a
great shot with the with the glowing out
of his head yeah that's a great shot and
you pointed this out while I was putting
together the reaction that they're
really capitalizing now on the
relationship which at honestly from the
movie verse just the movie so I know in
the comics they have a relationship but
in the movie world it was I wasn't
really feeling it but were you feeling
it in civil war I was a lot more and
they set it up obviously at the end of
age of Ultron where he saves her you
know kind of when the whole city's
coming down and she just killed the yeah
but I don't know me personally I've seen
civil war several times and I just I
thought that they were doing a good job
just building it up more building it up
more and just adding a lot more
chemistry and just just again
progressing that relationship because I
personally was into it in Civil War
obviously they ain't go full-blown but
they were really into a word I mean you
got that line from vision at the during
the airport scene where sister it's like
I said catastrophe like you can tell
obviously like he cares deeply he has a
deep affection and care for well the the
big reveal about this part of the
trailers there are a couple now you know
yeah like you see them and you see that
she's in laying in bed and this is very
intimate what's going on and he's really
change he's he's in human form now which
i think is a smart move he's evolving
because especially with all of us
theorizing that cuz vision has the mind
stone and he's collecting the stones and
everyone knows that the characters are
gonna probably die this time around it
seems like it's it's a foregone
conclusion we're gonna lose our pal
vision because he survived a lives off
having the mind stone so making him
human form at will automatically I feel
for a human audience make you care more
about vision yeah I wonder if he has a
different name now if it's Jarvis Jarvis
again yeah margin is his name our dances
name and yeah the effects of that do
look really cool that might be the
Milano the guardianship Oh with a shot
of Thor right here yeah I love this shot
right here who do you see in the next
hold buster
and you know what Conda I think it's
Wakanda looks like Wakanda might maybe
taking the technology there recruiting
the Black Panther for this mission and I
love to seeing the Hulkbuster hang
because obviously you know Bruce Banner
helped him create that suit as mentioned
in Avengers age of Ultron like I helped
you build it remembers yeah I think
that's just a cool moment like again
reminding us like that thing punched him
in the head several times I do in the
battle of the age of Ultron what I'm
wondering if this is actually after the
ending part here because the Hulk's
there and you don't see Tony Stark here
you don't see a lot of the other
Avengers in war machine though where
that look right there war machine that
is war machine okay okay never mind
this is caps team right here and except
for you know of course having war
machine so maybe actually that's after
cuz my mom one theory I had was Hulk
shows up after when he hears the Hulk is
back and he's Apple Conda in this moment
so let's go back a little bit more let's
go through it a little bit because
because yeah which I mean Black Widow
new hair Black Widow yeah yeah and Plus
you know all of us are not working off a
much sleep right now so okay so hope
okay never mind that sanctum say yeah I
got to remember how this trailer unfolds
because Hulk is is here with Doctor
Strange he gets found there and this is
gonna be great I just decided to pretty
ho crash in the second I mix oh that's
where the holy okay so he crashed into
the sanctum sanctorum okay baby Doctor
Strange yeah something cuz we saw an
thor ragnarok like member of Loki I have
been falling yeah so maybe he did
something whereas all Hulk was falling
and he put him in some kind of portal
and then he fell into the sanctum
sanctorum
I don't unless you just conveniently
fell yeah I'm saying Torme of all places
in the world well I'm wondering Howard
that honey
he showed up there with the doctor
strange contact and what excites me
about this scene is dr. strange and Tony
- Sherlock's no [ __ ] Sherlock
I can't wait for that excited to see
well yeah so but dr. strange and Bruce
Banner talk because they're both you
know science guys also yeah one's a
doctor on science yeah well something
goes on here because if you look at this
shot they all they're all looking here
for some reason Tony's the only one was
like I'll go check it out and then they
have that shot a little bit later we're
more attention where right here where
chaos has just taken place and for some
reason Tony went out firstly Sudan he
just had to go and find out what was
going on but it's all going on in New
York this I'm assuming this is probably
the second act right here when Thanos
invades the black order invades and yeah
that's some Spidey gets the spy so I
imagine like it's gonna be a series of
shots where you see a lot of them going
what's going on out there yeah and I
like the progression of spider-man - or
obviously against spoilers if you
haven't seen spider-man homecoming but
at the end of that film he makes the
choice to just be you know your friendly
neighborhood spider-man keep his feet on
the ground obviously now at this point
he doesn't really have a choice yes I do
like how just in one visual shot they
make it very clear like he has no no uh
basically he has no uh no chair he has
to figure out basically basically he has
no choice at this point he has to help
the team out whether he likes it or not
because the the world threat level has
had an all-time high obviously yeah and
this is a cool tease at his spidey sense
and actually kicking in because you're
seeing a lot of growth happen this is
obviously taking place later as I know
the guardians are supposed to be four
years old 2014 that's when both one and
volume two both took place until no I
mean I think there's a Russo brothers or
James Gunn confirmed that when they meet
them the guardians enter here they are
four years old yeah yeah then guardians
of the galaxy volume two yeah that's
what I'm saying those movies took both
took place in 2014 oh okay they are four
years to your point they're four years
old if four years older and so but it
also looks like things have changed with
these guys a lot I mean you see vision
and and Scarlet Witch are together right
now spider-man has spidey sense now so
I'm I'm interested to see like what all
the other updates that are going on yeah
be interested see like how obviously
when we last saw Captain America he was
a fugitive on the run so like it's gonna
be interesting to see the transition of
alright you're still a fugitive but the
world is about to end I need your help
you know and see Tony and his relation
to patch up a little bit from that
moment and what happens so it's gonna be
interesting what makes sense that cap
would be there because he kept Bucky hid
in their condo in Wakanda so I assume
that they go what I imagine probably is
Tony wants to recruit black panther
because they had their encounter at
Civil War I don't know or maybe he does
happen Tony tends to have that habit of
like yeah I know where cap has been
located this entire time I just haven't
tracked him down you know yeah but right
here Loki the tesseract man so it so
that that does confirm after the events
of Thor Ragnarok because and Thor
Ragnarok they hint at did he take it
for me to take it yeah and he definitely
takes it and it's also a callback to the
first event at night Captain America
first ventures but Joss Whedon's the
Avengers yeah it calls back to he made a
deal with Thanos he gets to rule over
Earth but he's got to give Thanos the
tesseract and back the the scepter so of
the mind stone and that's the space
stone so he's giving fan was back what
they made their original deal from the
first Avengers film so do you guys think
he's gonna be like that is exactly 100%
what's going on he's giving it to Thanos
right looking at beard panic in his face
I'm just giving it to Thanos otherwise
they're in my yeah there can't be
another space ball it's a space portal
you're right yeah because he's sorry
guys camera cuts every 12 minutes yeah
this is a space portal right here no
that's what the that's what the mine
stone does I mean that the mine stone
all nighters right here man the effects
on that so yeah Loki that is a
confirmation that Loki was
he did steal the stone the tesseract
and/or Ragnar and that also you're right
in Odin's vault that also calls back
again to the first event to Joss
Whedon's the Avengers the first one when
Loki made a deal with Thanos and the
deal was you get to rule of earth but
you've got to bring me back the mine
stone as well as give me the space stone
yeah so obviously if Loki is just
fulfilling his end of the bargain
because I remember the other that
character the one who was speaking for
Thanos making the dialogue with yeah
yeah yeah he was saying like if you
don't you know give Thanos this like
there's gonna be nowhere you can hide or
run you could see that fear and panic so
I like to call about a lot of the
callbacks and references to I mean
obviously everything that's come before
this but the first Avengers film yeah
yeah definitely man well I love designs
there looks so good
I just love any moment or Loki's force
to take something serious yeah also the
iron spider-man the iron spider suit
white suit not not very long to wait
until we get to see that thing and hey
damn it looks fat it does look amazing
all these designs look like to chari
designs it would make sense at you
that's what they're called right to
charge target re yeah I remember the
smelling yeah they look like Chitauri
designs which would makes sense because
it is bringing it like full circle and
all and all of it and they were part of
his like damn ass as minions and when it
confirms the post-credits scene in that
make credit scene and Avengers the first
one well I like to that with this
they're bringing in some of those more
cosmic designs because that next shot of
Thor in that giant yeah turbine thing
and what looks like a part of the
spaceship or whatever like I I do kind
of see better how they're gonna crash
these two sides of the moral universe
together because this is gonna be big
like having the guardians enter and
having the big more cosmic exhaust yeah
like fully meld in along with Doctor
Strange and stuff like I'm excited so
you gonna be interesting to see a cosmic
story in a grounded story like kind of
submerge with each other and see that
yeah balance works but what I like about
this shot right here with Thor's like
well of it it kind of reminds me of a
from Captain America so helicopter
where he's making all of us male yeah
yeah we vote in homecoming that was kind
of a car like a little did Tobey Maguire
and spider-man because you have it's
bicep shows doing his workout right now
I didn't realize that this was filming
well I imagine that this scene is
probably what takes place before the
ship crashes on to earth because from
what we've seen with Hulk crashing into
dr. Strange's place and then you know it
looks like it's gonna keep the ship
together yeah I wouldn't that would be
cool if even if this wasn't even the
Milano
with the Guardians if this was less you
just said his ship at the end of thor
ragnarok that'd be interesting if that's
possible what's happening here - one of
those - the d23 trailer says he's
floating in space so I imagine this ship
falls apart and then that's how he
eventually bumps into the Guardians
because that's what it that's what it
says in at least the d23 description I
rented the trailer that is correct who's
his character against far the black
order I got Proxima midnight here in
Proxima midnight she's one of the black
orders he's one of Thanos's children and
in the comics she was actually married
to the the right hand of Thanos who was
Corvus glaive what's interesting about
her she is a master hand-to-hand
combatant she's got all the fun things
like superhuman strength and speed and
that kind of stuff she's also she's
pretty close to invulnerable so she's
pretty damn hard to kill also - like I
just such as amazing at hand-to-hand
combat so if she's got you in her
crosshairs there's a good chance you're
going down also one final note about her
spear it is so powerful it can pet you
down to a molecular level one time in
the comic books she took that spear cut
it into Hulk and turned him back into
dr. Bruce and then no Magister Captain
America two sketches like adds nothing
well that's it that's a big point of
intrigue for me with this movie is
seeing how much does the black order
we're gonna get to know a good amount
some pretty interesting character
because that was one of my things like
even though I love seeing the Avengers
just plow through that you tari and plow
through yeah drone even though it kind
of felt more of a repeat in age of
Ultron with the plowing through the
drones there's a lot of henchmen yeah
yeah but I didn't mind it because of how
sick the actions but what I think I'm
gonna appreciate more about the black
they're not just going through like you
know crabs like this actually ups the
stay closed and makes the threat level
oh yeah a lot more creative and also too
it gives the some of the villains more
personality more of a backstory gives
them a chance to expand their characters
with drones and Chitauri everything
really it gives you a real threat level
as opposed to just yeah heroes rock n
roll this it feels like this this feels
like they need to assemblies that your
villain Ted and version of a guitar X I
think in this scene because Black
Panther is saying get this man get this
man a shield love that one
I imagine with neo cap dressing the way
he is and what the beer he has and his
hair is longer that maybe after the
events of civil war he kind of gave up
on the whole idea of fighting and you
know fighting for what's right and
justice because it seems like he just
keeps getting [ __ ] over after Winter
Soldier and after Civil War you got to
imagine this guy's like what's the point
I don't even see the point of fighting
I've just been lied to all the freakin
time
and I imagine Black Panther in some ways
a motivator for cap in this moment and
he did say at the end of Civil War
though to Tony if you ever need me I'll
be there that's true
that is true he did say that and I do
love how it's a black panther
T'Challa saying get this man is she of
it of course he's a he's the king of
Wakanda who you know they were the ones
who carry what kind of irony I brainy
close dude we're gonna get ahead with
Marvel clothes man I'm really wondering
how this who she is she's striking
someone who looks like she's stabbing
one of it could be one of the black
order possibly maybe it's uh
Corbis believe she's attempting I'm like
trying to wonder what I know everyone
always says this and all the movies but
like what our Black Widow and Hawkeye
supposed to do against one of those
black order characters like they're so
powerful the interesting you see how
they do that I imagined this fight is
when cap is like alright I'm getting
back in the field right here something
gives you the impression with the
footage of the shortness of these few
action scenes that this is all within
the first half of the movie not not like
the last half but most but in this
moment right here and see this possible
with Thanos crushing Spidey and then I
mean I'm sure that's not part of the
same scene where they have light tones I
started looking over there just cutting
it to make it look like that's what he's
seeing why wouldn't he be wearing his
suit his suit could have been like you
said destroyed right about here and now
he's seeing his team members getting
like killed misses the vision he had
what and Scarlet Witch because you see
in this in the same environment moments
where he has the suit on and he's
fighting with it so maybe get stripped
away this moment right here though I
mean it's definitely Corvus glaive you
can tell that's Corvus glaive spear
right there that he's ripping it out
with assignments a mistake no that's
Corvus glaive right there taking it out
because that spear it's got the same
shape as Corvus glaive from the comics
and this blade that's bare really quick
about Corvus glaive what he is he's
basically he's the right hand to Thanos
and he is a master tech tactician in
warfare if he started strategist if he
studies your warfare like earth for
instance you're done you're finished he
knows how to take you out immediately
knows all the weak points so and also to
that spear that particular spear right
there the glaive that keeps him immortal
if you try and kill him you incinerate
him you try and do whatever if you do
not destroy that blade or keep it intact
you cannot kill him wow this is cool man
I like because the hype has been for
Thanos and I feel like we're gonna get
instead of an introduction of a bunch of
new heroes we're gonna get an
introduction of a bunch of new villains
now yeah thing in my mind I thought
famous was gonna bring back some of the
villains from the previous phases like
maybe bring the Red Skull and from
Captain America First Avenger because we
saw he had the tesseract and went into
space we have no idea what happened
obviously Hugo Weaving doesn't really
want to do the role very much but
obviously is under contract and it
doesn't really have a choice but I agree
with you I love that we're gonna get the
black order and also we got hinted at
the black order from guardians of the
galaxy when he says you you apparently
you alienated my favorite daughter
Gamora and also nebula says to Gamora
of all our siblings I hated you the
least so we got our foreshadowing in our
hints of fantasy yeah children early on
in 2014 in guardians of the guy
so this is kind of a building block to
them in terms of from 2014 this Warriors
is me this has been a strong building
block because as much as we feel like
oftentimes we can be like you know the
the future setups get thrown in our
faces a lot when we were watching some
video just to get familiar again with
some of the Infinity stones
I really dawn on John and I like you
know they've been building this up
really well and not as in my face as I
thought no yeah yeah the build up at
least of the the small details that are
about to become major is really yeah you
know they do an amazing job with that if
one baby thing I would just throw in
there is an example of that is in
Captain America Winter Soldier you see
just little newspaper clippings when
Captain America when Steve Rogers and
Natasha Romanoff go into the Hydra layer
and you know we have the computer saying
all the the exposition but basically
what we get there are looms Olaf we get
there is just from the little snippets
that's where I came up with the idea Oh
the Winter Soldier killed Tony Stark's
parents because they give you a little
ground they give you a little hints
there now you really see how methodical
they are they really go through this and
think about this is gonna be epic and
also you see vision here and he is not
in human form also too when you can take
down vision and it looks like almost
with ease like that's how power because
I think that's why I wanted to show the
vision getting taken down like that's
how powerful these care they took down
visions that throughout level that
really did because vision is the
Superman of the team vision vision took
in the last Avengers movie vision took
care of the villain yeah yeah I think to
your point when you were like why are
they showing visions we all could have
guessed that they were gonna do but I
think they wanted to show you how
powerful the black yeah it's partly to
raise the stakes because you know that
that's gonna have to happen yeah more
than that sacrifice and it's good to cuz
they keep talking about not everyone's
gonna make it through this and that's a
good way to start that you know vibe
without giving away the surprises yeah I
gotta tell you I don't freaking love all
of these costumes and suits there yeah
oh so freaking amazing they look great
everything like in it this looks like
the first Marvel film that might have
true definitive cinematography like the
just the imagery on here live I feel
like a lot of the times the
cinematography and looks kind of similar
here the lighting and the framing looks
very specific it looks very composed you
know and I love yeah it's like the Russo
brothers are trying to stamp their own
like said yeah cinematography look on
the film to get that feel like I like
yet all these characters are one movie
you got to have that cinematography
stamp you got to find the right look the
right tone the right color and it looks
like they found it man it looks amazing
it looks beautiful and yeah and like
they're the the facets of their world
and the visual palette is is expanding
yet again I also make sense that it
would broaden out here yeah I agree and
I also love how this film is opening on
May 4th obviously Star Wars day may the
4th be with you but it's also it's the
same day that the first Avengers came
out and back into this well recall May 4
2012 what's what's cool about this
moment right here every 12 minutes of
cuts what's cool about this moment right
here you can see right here Groot is
still teenager for years Mantis is part
of the official team loving it loving
well I remember that I was a James Gunn
or the Russo brothers said the guardians
are four years older in this movie and
it seems like everyone has sort of age
everyone has sort of grown you know I
see the drama of Gamora and nebula like
we you know with Thanos and like is it's
their dad obviously taken over their
adoptive father but to me personally
this is just my own little theory
I think nebulas got to be the one in the
fourth movie out in the comics she does
doesn't she I think in the kind of
safety right I'm gonna be right but just
from the lines we've gotten from these
films and from everything all the
torture we we saw that nebula had been
through in guardians of the galaxy
bottom to where she said that every time
she lost a good mornin Dan oh yeah
that's why she loves the way she does
yeah she's got to be the one who kills
Thanos in the second bender
part four well that's why I think ending
what the Guardians is great because
there's that's the personal relationship
right there having Gamora right there
goes this is the personal stuff that
once we're really tied to Thanos
everyone just kind of knows if that
knows now or no stano's and this is a
relation yeah and that's gonna be
interesting to see from Thanos
perspective like does he hesitate at all
when he sees his favorite daughter
Gamora now I don't care I want everyone
to pay tribute to me I just want to
destroy everything yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see if they give Thanos a
human side or a human element even
though he wants to destroy an
incinerator beam because it's his
daughter right okay there is gonna be
some interesting complicated
complications there even from the bad
guys perspective well let's hear that
audio again just one more time there's
definitely some Avengers callbacks in
the audio as me of this Scarlet Witch
nightmare Tony's finishing the line for
Nick Harry to see if we could become
there all the lines from the first
trailer the first Avengers film they
show the person with the voice whatever
is this vo or the trailer if it is vo
for the sheriff they're all actually
from the dialogue from the first trailer
yeah that same dialogue between Nick
Fury with Nick Fury said the band's that
sounds like fury says it but all the
other characters for sale what if it's
an actual scene or if they're just the
other trailer the trailer and that music
that sounds the best
from the first Avengers film
[Music]
Dustin's gonna
what boy looks good
[Music]
so he's enjoying this he likes the man
hand he wants he wants world destruction
once I wouldn't about it once tribute oh
the money shot that's the turnaround
shot from Avengers remember not yet not
yet because you're gonna oh yeah one
shot I mean captain Marvel's not in this
film so she's gonna be I mean she's got
her solo film coming out after this with
brie Larson and then obviously she's
gonna be one of the this movie and my
opinion not a very you know hard
prediction but it's gonna end kind of
like Empire Strikes Back on a downer
where they lose and you know Thanos's
kind of gotten most of the most of the
Infinity stones or all of them and it's
like okay what do we do now and then
maybe Captain Marvel is the one who is
the one you know brings them back and
helps them is that driving force and
maybe in her solo film we find out cuz
that film takes place in the 90s when
Nick Fury still had both eyes Samuel
Jackson will be in that film maybe that
film will tell us why where was she in
all these years around ya know wish is
she may be like in the Microverse where
you know a man's wife at where the hell
is she like did she go off to space
somewhere you know so it's gonna be he's
hanging with Adam warlock she's hanging
out with Jude Law know just got cast as
marvel her now we got the whole Sherlock
Holmes team both ie for her all for
Sherlock Holmes characters on both the
TV show the movies well I I can't wait
for I mean there's gonna be at least one
or two more trailers as it comes out now
we've got to see this movie in IMAX
though this whole movies shot in IMAX
I'm gonna wait for someone to record it
off of the phone and then download that
yeah alright guys what are your
predictions on who do you thinks gonna
die in this movie don't say vision get
more creative who do you think will die
in this movie
Ange I want to thank you for being here
so early in the morning you woke up at 4
your buddy John I wanna thank you for
pulling an all-nighter with me buddy
thank you guys for watching this video
please subscribe to the channel you can
become a patron eject today I'll be post
exclusive daily content on
and we also you know help support the
channel andrea movie source channel does
great analysis great breakdance with
some awesome theories go check out his
channel as soon as you can
take care follow some started oh yeah
that one yeah with our link and follows
first